our city has come a long way and our
city is ready
for leadership um that has
a unique perspective so my lived
experience
is very different than the 54 mayors
mayors that have come before me
uh for for sure and i bring that lens i
bring that unique lens as a woman i
bring that lens
as as a woman of color that was kim jani
who will be
sworn in tomorrow as the next mayor of
boston
she will become the first woman and the
first black person
to ever lead the city this month we're
celebrating women and we have
a lot of milestones like that to be
proud of the us has its first woman
and person of color as vice president
women leaders like new zealand's prime
minister jacinda arden
are doing a better job at responding to
the covid crisis
and for the first time two women
received the nobel prize
for chemistry which is really dope but
we can't forget
that men built the system and gender
remains
a barrier to total equality women still
make only 82 cents for every dollar a
man makes
and despite being over half of the
population
a fact i like to repeat often women only
make up 27
of congress but as activist and feminist
gloria steinem puts in her international
women's day op-ed
we just need to keep going steinum has
been part of the fight for equality for
decades
she was the founder of the national
women's political caucus
and one of the driving forces behind the
creation and passage
of the equal rights amendment which just
re-passed in the house without
an expiration date and joining me now is
feminist icon
gloria steinem i am so excited
that you are here today how are you
doing today
i'm so excited to see you and i'm so
grateful for that segment
that you just did on gun control i mean
that is such a genuine thank you so much
right no absolutely absolutely
i think this figures in in a way to our
subject because
i think this is a very good moment for a
gun
buyback program uh because uh
women have been very clear many women
that they want to get guns out of the
house
and to be able to offer money for them
as some police departments are doing is
very helpful
absolutely so in terms of those policies
you mentioned a gun buyback program what
are some of the other policies that you
think
really need to be implemented or passed
by this particular congress in the wake
of the shootings that we've seen in the
past week
well i do think from a philosophical
point of view
that we need to point out who the
shooters are
uh i mean i watched all the
reports of the men who invaded the
capital
and very few said hello these are what
guys
i mean in every single mass shooting
has been committed by
a white male now you know that's
certainly not to demonize
all white men but i think it does tell
us that what we are doing
is too often is talking about women
catching up
with men instead of men catching up with
women
and just challenging the
gender and the race roles at the base
that is such an important point and
you've talked so much in the past
about the need to democratize the family
as the basis to really get a full
democracy
in our country because our gender no our
gender roles are
established uh people are very much um
you know especially in the republican
side they want the quote-unquote
traditional family
how can we upend that because i i find
that as an older millennial
i'm almost 40 um and i i'm independent
i'm unmarried i don't have any kids
um and i think there's a lot of women my
age i know in my friend group who are
trying to sort of
lay out their own path you know not be
confined to
the expectation of marriage and children
um
that that we've you know been that have
been prescribed for us
well you know i think that that's
changed a lot i mean i am exactly in
your situation
and i'm happy i just want to say
uh and in my generation the idea that
you had to marry and have children and
take his name and his identity and so on
was way stronger than it is right now
so you know we we have truly made
change but i think while women have
advanced
it's not necessarily that men have
advanced too i mean if children have two
parents
there's this revolutionary idea that men
should
take care of them 50 percent of the time
uh and you know women
are so aware of this i remember being in
in a lecture where a woman stood up you
know
apparently shy woman and she said you
know
when my husband leaves his underwear on
the floor
i find it quite useful to nail it to the
floor
you know struggle
uh going on and it it that's not
at all minute it's the most basic
because the
single biggest indicator of whether a
country will go to war
against another country is actually not
poverty or border conflicts or oil
or the things we read about it is
violence in the family uh
that the sort of hierarchical
that is what normalizes violence if we
see that in the family
uh we come to think it's inevitable so
if we want to i mean it is the key to
world peace not to be
you know but it is uh
but we don't we we i think still
um compartmentalize women's issues
as if they weren't and racial issues too
as if they weren't connected to
absolutely everything else
so speak speak to that connection and
that intersection because i think
especially in this moment in 2021 we've
we've lived in a through a pandemic or
we are living through a pandemic we're
surviving a pandemic
most people haven't done that i think
there's one woman that
was here for 1918 i think they did find
the one person
um so so it's all unprecedented but at
the same time there are
issues that have been you know we've
been dealing with for decades
um and that's why i think you saw you
know the racial reckoning through the
summer
so speak to the intersection and that
connection between
the fight for racial justice and the
fight for gender equality because
they are so connected no in in a very
fundamental way they're intertwined
because
you can't maintain racial differences
without controlling women's bodies
as the means of reproduction i mean you
know look at the long history
of racist laws against so-called
miscegenation
and the uh punishment
terrible punish ridiculous punishment
for
black men who had any contact uh
with white women and you know that
race and sex are intertwined and there's
no way to uproot one
without also uprooting the other
um i think also we see this in the
activism of black women
i mean look at the last election you
know i mean black women are way more
uh active and and uh
you know right on the issues than
than either white women are black men
so just statistically speaking right
uh and and i know i was like we
yeah we're fighting for everybody
right yeah and i think because the
experience is there
you know the understanding is there
absolutely so i want to turn now to some
of the news that's been in the headlines
lately
you know new york governor andrew cuomo
is under fire and there are multiple
investigations
or he's under investigation for multiple
allegations excuse me
for sexual of sexual harassment what are
your what are your thoughts i mean do
you think you should resign
and what are your feelings about how
he's reacted to the allegations because
i also think there is there's a
teachable moment there as well for men
who are accused of this type of
misconduct
well i i would just say to him that it's
perfectly clear
that the most helpful thing you can do
for yourself
if you are guilty is to say you are
guilty
tell the truth apologize and
take whatever action is appropriate now
everyone is entitled to an investigation
you know that's true too so um
that that should go forward but the
great sign of progress here is that the
women have come forward
i mean those uh acts would have been
not only thought to be inevitable but
blamed on women in the recent past you
know
why were you there alone with him in the
office what were you wearing
you know so i'm so grateful to the
massive me too movement
which has helped to change this
and it hasn't been that long i mean i
remember when the word
sexual harassment the phrase was
invented you know that was
only in the 70s and it was women at
cornell university who were trying to
describe what happened to them at their
summer jobs
and then it was uh written into sex
discrimination law
and and three women i think all black
women brought the first cases
uh and then there was anita hill you
know i mean this is the
you can see uh the um
the progression so you know
we have come a long way towards
understanding
that the basis of democracy is bodily
integrity
either we have control yes over our own
physical
selves and male or female no one can
touch us
without it not just permission i would
say
which is a kind of low level but unless
it's welcome
that's a wonderful word for us as well
yeah i like that welcome exactly um
you partnered with google google arts
and culture on a new project called a
home
for a movement tell us about this
project and why you decided to do it
you know i'm so proud of this
project because we
need especially as women spaces to meet
and to feel safe
and you know ironically because i've
been living in the same couple of floors
in a brownstone
for half a century or more uh
it has been used at that space as that
kind of space
you know people come and stay overnight
or we have meetings or
so it occurred to me and especially to
amy richards who's my colleague
that we could continue this
and i have left my
apartment to a foundation so
it will be there forevermore so
people can continue to use it in this
way
i mean you know sometimes i think it's
just because
i don't want to think about moving but
[Laughter]
i can relate to that
and it's very deeply very deeply
it's it's it's also a way of preserving
not only space
but particular items that are
meaningful if i came to your house there
would be things there that
i inspired me right so
yeah right we can we can do that for
each other
and also we are
communal animals as human beings i mean
we have always been
sitting around a campfire telling our
stories
and we need places to do that
so i'm very very proud that um
you know that my apartment will
continue to be used in that way
it's really amazing gloria steinem thank
you so much
for taking the time today and for being
here and happy early birthday
um that is exciting as well please thank
you
so glad to see you and i hope
we actually meet okay all right
yes we will see we'll meet again yes
hi i'm zerlina maxwell thanks for
checking out our channel on youtube
you can see more from zerlina by
clicking any of the videos on this
screen
and make sure you subscribe below to
stay up to date on the day's biggest
stories
thanks for watching